dear comrades,
on February 24, a special military
operation began in ukraine,
carrying out the assigned tasks to protect
our people in the donbas to ensure the
security of our homeland,
russian soldiers and officers
act courageously like real
heroes,
our servicemen immediately fight
standing with full understanding of the right
you will never give up yours
the belief that Russians and Ukrainians
are one people, even though
some of the inhabitants of Ukraine were intimidated by many
fooled by Nazi nationalist
propaganda,
and someone deliberately, of course, followed the
path of Bandera’s other
Nazi henchmen who
fought on the side of Hitler during the Great Patriotic War,
our soldiers and officers strive
to prevent casualties among the civilian
population and, unfortunately, they themselves suffer
losses,
our duty is to support the families of our dead
and injure comrades-in-arms who
fought for the security of the fatherland for
our people for the people of Russia, dear
comrades, I want to say that special  The
military operation is proceeding in strict
accordance with the schedule according to the plan, all the
assigned tasks
are being successfully solved
[applause]